when the sirens go off people head to
the shelter in odessa is deep
underground in the so-called catacombs
all stone mines excavated through times
like and her children have been coming
and going from here since the beginning
of the war
they have supplies ready for the long
haul
look we have water here are the blankets
we have to sleep here
mats and two inflatable mattresses and
here we keep food a lot of different
things biscuits liver pate and different
cans of food i have the passports and
all the documents in my bag as soon as i
hear the sirens i pick up the children
and come down here
this is the largest urban labyrinth in
the world and portions of it have been
prepared for civilians to hide about a
thousand can fit in this part
down here it's a different world you
can't hear anything of what's happening
above they're about 2
500 kilometers of tunnels and
passageways now this place has already
been used as a shelter during previous
wars and during the cold war it was
designated as a nuclear bunker
sections of it could also be used by the
military to move undercover
the city is under threat of a
three-pronged attack from the northeast
the black sea and the north west
the main risk today is an amphibious
landing russians are trying to put
psychological pressure on ukrainians by
shelling from the sea and from the sky
they are trying to demonstrate their
strength they certainly have it but our
defense system is ready to repel any
attack
they are probing our defenses to find
vulnerable points and mark them as
targets
around the city volunteers are preparing
for the worst
this foothold usually bustling with
tourists is now the headquarters of the
humanitarian effort sponsored by some of
the most influential business people of
odessa
the public library is one of the few
places still open but here no more books
in russian since the conflict started in
2014.
russia's great authors can be found
translated in ukrainian tucked on the
upper floor
ukrainian odessa is not as small as it
might seem and there is no need to
support the russian narratives that
odessa is a russian city and speaks only
russian no
i think that people are now switching to
ukrainian
i really hope that odessa will not
return to pro-russian narrative anymore
explosions and air sirens are heard more
often every day and night
a sign that for odessa the light at the
end of the tunnel may still be far away
al jazeera odessa in southern ukraine